All those times your mother told you to play
outside because playing on the Internet is
ruining your brain?
Well, turns out she might have been wrong.
Sort of.
Hello everyone!
Amy coming to you on the Internet today talking
about, well, how using the Internet might
be affecting your brain.
And the good news if you’re under 25?
Your internet and social media habits aren’t
necessarily damaging.
Specifically, we’re talking about time spent
on social media sites like Facebook.
The issue with Facebook, according to some
scientists, is that teenagers spending an
increasing amount of time on social media
sites are stunting their neurologic development.
The human brain doesn’t reach full maturity
until we’re in our mid-20s.
Before that, during early and mid-adolescence,
the brain undergoes considerable growth and
pruning, particularly in the forward cerebral
cortex and the prefrontal cortex, the area
behind the forehead.
This is the area associated with planning
and problem-solving related tasks.
As it develops, the prefrontal cortex communicates
more effectively with other parts of the brain.
So, you can kind of imagine that any activity
that affects the cerebral and prefrontal cortex
could seriously affect the individual’s
development as well.
Things like excessive Internet usage.
One European-based study found that nine in
ten adults go online in any location, more
than doubling the number of hours spent online
each week in the last decade from ten hours
to more than 20.
So is it possible, as some scientists have
suggested, that the increase in social networking
site usage is negatively affecting how we
relate to others emotionally and gain a sense
of personal identity in this critical phase
of neural development?
No.
At least, not according to scientists at University
College London and the University of Oxford
who say that there is no evidence from neuroscience
studies to show that typical internet use
harms the adolescent brain.
If anything, it’s actually useful.
Rather than hamper social interaction, adolescents’
use of social networking sites has been found
to enhance the overall quality of friendships
and relationships.
The team also found that people generally
portray their lives accurately, making online
interaction closer to in person connections.
Moving beyond the social side, the same research
team found that computer games don’t necessarily
lead to impulsiveness, a shorter attention
span, or aggression.
And as for the idea that easy access to search
engines breeds superficial mental processing
rather than deep knowledge and understanding,
the researchers say it’s impossible to blame
technology alone for this change in thought
process; a lot of things can contribute to
the way a person thinks.
But this isn’t to say that spending all
your time online is a good thing.
There are still negative effects, though it’s
an indirect correlation.
It’s not technology affecting children's
capacities, it’s the fact that using technology
is displacing other activities that are equally
important for development.
And these are pretty easy correlations to
see.
Low levels of physical activity associated
with sitting around on the Internet have been
linked to obesity and diabetes.
And it’s the time spent playing video games
rather than doing homework that’s responsible
for dropping grades among teenage gamers,
not the games themselves.
So it’s not all bad.
Like pretty much everything, we just need
to make sure we have a good balance in our
lives, especially those among us whose brains
are still developing.
But are your online friends real friends?
Julia took at look at the science behind this
one:
How much time do you guys spend online every
day, and do you feel closer to your friends
for all the time spent snooping their facebook
pictures?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.